Come in BOI *awkward silence*
*moist sounds* You too fat?
Moisty: oh FUCK no
I want you all to shake your dicks
As much as you can right now
Get it up in the air... I don't care if you are a girl,*rethinks life* or a dinosaur, or whatever the fuck
*nervous laughing*
We have absolutely no fucking ammo (because pewds can't aim)
And this bitch is off the building
There was a fucking door here... Jesus Christ (duh)
Okay
That's fine...
And a broken elevator... great
Ahh... come on, you can squeeze through Mia(she a fatass)
You could- I could squeeze through that, come on (it's a game pewds it's meant to annoy you)
God damnit, I feel like I'm being watched O-O (pewds you're being watched by 8 million people)
I dont like it :(
And I'm not talking about you it's fine... you can look all you want... it's all good ;)
You shook your dick a little bit too much that was kinda fucking weird
Need a lockpick, machine gun... I don't have a focking machine gun(m8)
Do I look like I got a fucking machine gun
OH MY GOD! It's a machine-nah... :(
Are you fucking kidding me?
Am I that much of an idiot? (yes)
Why are you even watching me(well...)
I'm such a fucking moron(that's true)
Jesus Christ
Okay we need something but we can go up here... so it's okay
That looks very dangerous *chuckles* (yes it does)
I'd be scared of touching this...
like metal
Have you seen those videos online where people get electrified and they just fucking die? (no?)
Sorry, I didnt mean to be morbid but (i'm going to have nighmares now)
It's always so interesting to me (wtf pewds)
Now I just sound like a pyschopath, Jesus Christ (you need to calm)
You said-uh... I didn't click on it, alright?
Fuck
Maybe I'm a little bit psycho...I think that's okay (no it's not)
Anyway... oh Jesus
Hey! we're in the main room
What do we got?
Alright, luckily the elect-
Electricity is working on this fucking computer
Change camera
Oh, that's where we were
Yeah, we've been here
(ovo what's this)
Is that him?
It looks like a blob to me
S2, he's in S2
(jumpscare in 3)
(2, prepare your butts)
Ugh... (1)
*scared Pewds noises*
I'll fucking kill you
Fucking *regenerate face*
Oh my god, my own shadow scared me
So that was just a halu-lu-se (wtf)
*weird cult singing*
*more*
*and more* (pewds going insane)
Ey we got some gun powder~ :D
Just wanna make sure I loot everything
'Cause we need as much ammo as we can get~
Okay, well it seems like we have to go down here
*tch* What do you say partner? (no)
What do you say old pal? (no)
That's right I think
You're pal level, if you made it this far in this playthrough
I drop the P's
Not the P--ahh whatever
Hey uh some of... some of that weed-uh
Wait, what is...
What's down here?
Is this the staircase?
It is!
Looks... blocked?
Luckily, we have a bomb placed very nicely
It's almost like we can blow that shit up
Should we do that? (no)
Should we waste it?
*wastes precious bomb* Bim-bada-bam-bada-boom :D
Are you fucking kidding me right now? D:< (told you)
God. Fucking. Damnit
Nooo
NOOO
WHAT?
Fuck youu!
I don't even- Ah! I don't even have a gun to sho-kn-knife, whatever...
God damnit
Worst playthrough on YouTube (I agree)
Hello everyone (hi pewds)
Top of the morning to ya
Oh look, it's Jacksepticeye (1)
A ship map
I'd realize we've literally never, EVER, watched the map (yes pewds)
We played the entire fucking game
wrong button... *awkward silence*
We played the entire fucking game without fucking watching the map
I don't even know how to watch the map
I mean, I got by fine without it, so I guess it's okay :D
Oh shit! There's the gun
The P-19
I want that shit dawg~
4-way... wrench
Useful for removing nuts
Ha, should give one to Marzia
Heyo
That made no sense
Jesus
Look at that view!
HEY! *slight giggle* (hey!) I didn't see you there, buddy! (pls help me)
Damn
Hey a bomb
I'll take it (pls don't waste it pewds)
Can we get up with this maybe?
Oh! okay
Cool
Hey, it's floating up by itself
Nice
How do I get down here?
There we go
Ow!
Ewwgh!
Oh my God, there's someone coming
Fuck
Climb up or down, I don't know!
I suppose we're supposed to go down
Fuck it, let's go up
See what happens
Top o' the morning to ya!
Oh fuck! What a sexy ass
Damn boi
Alright
Nice one
Oh my God, the aim is amazing (yes it is pewds)
Top o' *screams* THE MORNING!
Fuck, I gotta shoot the boxes, I don't have a knife
And it's a fucking bomb, God damnit
Ugh!
Alright, we need to loot everything we can right now Bros
Hello?
Hello, it's ya boy
Ethan Bradberry!
Is this our new hub? It sounds like it
IT IS!
Alright, cool
*singing* Save station, gotta love my save sta- *incoherent* bu-du-du-bu-du
Hey corrosive, we needed that, right?
Uhhh, for the door upstairs
We got nothing so
I don't know what
the fuck the point of that is
Not a bad hub area, I'll take it
Now, let's head out for new adventures
*singing* My name is Mia~
I wanna pee on ya~
That didn't really rhyme, did it?~
*mumbles* No it didn't~
Oh my god
It's Jacksepticeye. (A joke)
Alright, alright
We're gonna have to do one of these on you buddy,
*explosion* bye.
And you fuckin' dead, motherfucka
Uh oh
Top-o-the morning to ya ladur dur-dur.
Ew...
floor mop
She threw up in the fucking...
Cleaning container thing-a-ma jigger
What up, bitch
I just called her a bitch, hoping she would hear me, but I suppose...
suppose not- That hatch, is it still there? Yeah it is
Okay
Well let's explore... a bit more
What the fuck? This was not here before
Uh...
Okay
Heyy, some weed stuck in a couch
Alright, something's definitely happening in here
Should we waste it here?
I think it's worth it
Maybe it's just me but
I'm sure we're gonna find another one in here
There's the key, we needed that
Now we can get the machine gun!
YAS!
I'm so sorry for saying that, that'll never happen again
I swear on my life
Okay, I think that means we're done on this fucking floor
OH MY GOD, how did I MISS that?
Okay
So
I suppose we go back up?
There it is
I knew that. *nervous laugh*
Yeah.
Here we go.
What's making that fucking noise,  don't making me feel so uneasy game.
You fucking sneaky little fucking rat hole.
Fuck you man fucking hell
I'm closing the door from now on
I don't like you god dammit. I d-
Alright... we're a little bit more bad ass now
we gotta stay optimistic ... as okay... yeah yeah.
now we can go down in the hell hole
Known as jacksepticeye...
...butthole.
This is getting ridiculous
it's not even funny anymore
No not up.. f*ck sake.
We're going down to China town.
Oh god...
It's starti- What the fuck is making that sound?
Is someone pissing?
...
Great.
Just what i needed everyone,
just what I fuckin' needed. (Forgets to say "BOX")
I didn't even BOX! goddammit.
I'm so focused. (Sarcasm)
I-It's scary. (More sarcasm)
I'm gonna try and save my machine gun for like, if there's a boss fight or some sh*t coming up.
...and we clearly like- OH WE SAVED THE BOX
*Gasp* BOX!! *chuckles*
*Still chuckling* Dude this fuckin' knife meta though.
Damn dawg
*door opens* come in BOY
*monster sounds*
*Moist sounds* *Crawling monster feet sounds*
you too fat?
Wow! what a scary game...
OH GOD! Jesus! (Karma's a bitch)
JESUS!
NOOO!
I'm sorry I was joking!
joking- NO NOOOO!
FUCK I fucked up
OH close, nice
got em' *chuckles*
*mumbling* fuckin' asshole
oh wait-I fuck, I didn't see this
what is this?
AYEEE it's a puzzle
I love puzzles :D
okay
so- just, what? place them the right way?
*focused pewds is focused*
umm
well it's impossible to know
*turning sounds*
umm
there must be a hint...
*Footsteps and character breathing.*
Oh! Okay *awkward laughter*
Uh, so they're mirrored, right?
So that means this... *turning sounds*
... will have to be like that *Unlocking sounds*
Oh! I solved it! Wow *laughing*
And now we have all the corrosives!
...heck yes!
heck WOW!
Aww yeah! Bros
I don't know what's wrong with me either
sooo there was this door right? (yes pewds)
yes!
bam-bada-bam-bada-bam~
bada-boom *chuckles*
take that, DOOR
got em'
YES!
YES! more items!
HELL yeah
*heh* Actually just imagine,
Ethan just carrying like, 3 backpacks at once
*chuckles* just geared out
*Gasps*
I'm sorry but... this area sucks dick
eyeueyu fucking hell you gotta run everywhere
it's three uhhh f-floors
I-I don't know I get confused
It's like oh yeah I need to do that thing but
I don't rememeber where it was
so I just run around like a fuckin' idiot
for so long
tryin' to figure out like, oh, was this where I needed to go?
I dunno, it's a tricky area
Is this the control room?
yeah, yeah. this is it
I remember there's a door here...
there we go mamacita
senorita~
feel the congo, lemme see you move like a compobreobro
I never get sick of doing that, feels good :D
alright this looks like it could be it, Bros
*Pewds turns to Lickitung*
Hey! *Clunk* what a lovely view, let's look *Smaller Clunk*  at it together (aw, pewds)
wha- did I just take damage?
Wow it's so pretty, reminds me of my balls (wtf Pewds)
fuckin' huge (yikes)
Anyone who's seen me play this game know that's a fuckin' lie...
unless you've seen my balls (-_-)
sorry i-i-i-it got weird
I don't mean to make you uncomfortable
let's just keep playing
uhh
what is this?
*monster groaning*
*swedish* no! who did that?
ya know i got gifts for ya :D <3
*beeping sounds*
*monster groaning*
*EXPLOSION*
I got plenty more where that come from.
(Bad grammar Pewds strikes again!)
*Explodes*
*More monster groaning.* *2nd Explosion*
Can you fucking die please?
*Monster groaning it's last words*
Is it dead? x2
Is it fucking dead?
*moster explodes* *mia groans*
NO! Fuck, it exploded! Goddammit.
Damn you Jacksepticeye!
*Turning squeaky knob*
*Light voice* Oh! *laughs*
*Giggling* I love how meticulously we did that.
Just like d-doesn't explode at this fuckin' thing and then.
*Pewds impression of the squeaking noises.*
Just me?
Of course we needed this power cable
for uh...
...reasons
Hey! another one of those! :D
They don't seem to run out
*Slow beginning of music, that suddenly cuts.*
Oh!
I was literally just thinking: 'how the fuck do I fix it?'
And I accidentally fell down.
*Power starting up.*
Great (damnit pewds)
and here~ we go! :D
Nice. :3
Was it S2? (yes it was)
*light exhale* I am really like *pats chest* ohh
this part is really freaky to me
Eveline: He's waiting. Pewds: and it DOESN'T look better
Oh my God
Who's waiting?
*creepy sfx*
Fuck
Goddamnit this is freaky man
Oh God I hear enemies
*Box breaks* god enemies- BOX!
I ain't got time for you boys
*monster groaning*
*focused pewds*
Fuck, this is bad
*explosion*
Did that do the trick?
Sorta
You still alive? I can't tell
Great. Stay dead
Don't want-chu.
*creepy sfx*
Let's go in here~ how's it- top o' the mornin' to ya
How's everyone doin'? :D
I wanna go home, I wanna cry
I hate this boat, I fuckin' hate this boat
this boat is th- AUEGHH Jesus.
He's a strong one
He's cheating mom!
There we go. Nice
GOOOT EM'
HELL YEAH!
(headphone users rip) YYAAASS
*monster groaning* NO! D:<
OH GOD! It's Jacksepticeye
*incoherent* STop dOiN' dAt MaYnn
No. no >.<
GOOOT EM' you fuckin' fat son of a bitch
HEY! he did the barrel roll
*monster groaning* The backwards barrel roll may I add
Hey come a lil closer
come ma lady, come-come my lady
you're my butterf-
Come on, come on
Aight, aight you fuckin' dead now I'm fuckin' pissed
I'm fuckin' pissed now mate <(｀^´)>
Goddamn you so sexy! (╭ರ_•́)
You sexy, you loyal, I love-
*sexy pewds face*
BOOX-A!
*takes deep breath* Braaax!
How ya doin' buddy *sharp inhale* B- Ah you're not a box
Look at how much fuckin' shit we got all of a sudden
We have plenty of hand gun *Mumbles* ammo
Maybe i should... start using it (geez, really?! Wow!)
*creepy sfx*
Crazy thought, I know
We have *pauses* why not
HEY it's a coin everybody!
*Pewds Imitates Mia* "Ah"
"Eeeeh"
You getting tired there Mia? Oh I'm sorry
Uh, wrong room
*Sexually panting mia strikes again.*
Here we go
I'm gonna stock up a little bit first-
I think before this boss battle begins *nervous laughter*
Ayyy look at that
Now where were we?
Right. Thanks for waiting :D
Die? (pewds lmao)
Ethan! no. *unenthusiastic*
I need you to dance naked, while taking a shit~ (wtf pewds D:)
BRADBERRY!
That would be a nice easter egg if all this- *Interrupted by voice actor*
Ohh
WHAT?!
What the fuck?!( ͡ಠ ʖ̯ ͡ಠ)
It didn't seem like it dude.
*Imitating Old Man* Nor ma boy Lucas.
What??
She gets in your head, I guess.
Oh my godd... D: *Sad tone*
How does it work then?
That's why they keep saying part of the family D:
When did this happen?
When is this memory from?
Could it be have been from before we woke up by the kitchen table?
It's really interesting :D
We're playing as Ethan now
EEEW  (⁎˃ᆺ˂)
What the hell am I lookin' at? (confused pewds is confused)
This is all very confusing
EEEWWW! Ewwww! D:
EEEWWWH! >:((
What is all this!?
GROSS! >.<
Use your knife Mia
UGHHHHKCHH
Uh- she's right there
But I-
But she's right behind you D:
Aww come onnn
I thought we were gonna fight her as Mia!
This is all- okay, well I'm out *Laughs*
She was- right there. I don't know how
Did anyone fail to notice? She was...
right there
It's your fault, okay, whatever, i don't care
We don't have anything :(
Fuck I stocked up for no reason are you kidding me!?
wHaT?
No fucking way. -_-
I'm like, legit scared right now
I'm playing so late at night
and I'm a-alone at the office
it's fucking scary dude (it's OK Pewds you got us bros)
I don't know, when are you watching this?
I'm so glad we're out of the boat.
The boat was fuckin' terrible
*moist area making moist sounds*
It was my least favourite area (same pewds)
I mean it was good but damn.
I think you can agree (yeah)
*more moist sounds*
Oh. Look it's all dead fishes what is this Death Stranding?
Way to copy
Oh jeez it's getting uh
Usually not a good sign, to swim in a lake that looks like that   (⌣_⌣”)
Maybe they were dynamite fishing, who knows?
*creepy sfx*
Oh jeez
Don't attack me right now :(
I'm feeling very vulnerable
Okay...
the fuck is this?
Ammo. What are we gonna do with ammo?
Saaave station~
*singing* Gotta looove my save station :D
We got Mia's things? :0
Ooo :D
Okay we're heading out in the world.
We're heading back to the h- oh fuck. *gunshot*
Goddamnit
This gun is a LOT better
Jesus Christ
i'm fuckin' done (;-_-)ノ
Fuck you guys... not worth it
Did I use heavy ammo or some shit? I think I did
*blows into microphone*
It's so dark, it's just- nooo
and of course we're going down
of course
Jesus
What is this? mines?
okay well, that's not too bad :D
*monster groaning* Ohhh no
Why do I not block?
It's dead right? yeah
Oh my God
Okay
Could've just dodged it, but ya know
*error 404: pewds.exe. has stopped working*
*Chuckles*
*whispers* Oh for fucks sake
BOX! *Giggles*
BOX *fails* BOXXX
Don't know why I wasted a- Fuck, man
*blows into microphone* C'mon Pewds you can do this
You GOT this   (ﾒ▼_▼)
C'mon man
Come on, man! You got this man
Oh God, more? God enemies
Goodbye
Uh oh, uh oh
didn't work, did it? (no pewds)
Yeah tha's right, keep dancin'
IN HELL
Oh God! It's still alive! It just doesn't have any limbs D:
*AHAHA* It's like a pancake
EEWWWW
That's awesome dude (monster: why thank you pewds :D)
good for you
Stop.
Don't make me poke you to death.
Bad boy <(｀^´)>
Don't lick my nuts...
only Marzia. Only Marzia
Come on
Sorry that was weird (that was obscene, pewds)
OK here we go
This could be going a lot better :D
I need to save the bombs for the Bl-boomers or whatever
can we push this down maybe?
Yeah
*incoherent screaming* (rip headphone users)
YEAH! Son
It's ya boy, P to the Pie motherfucka
Sorry that sounded terrible (nah not really)
I don't even know why I even try
There's a hole there
Always gotta check for loot! Always
rule number one at this game: *puts on voice* check for loot
Did u check for loot, Pewds?
Well then you die.
You die and you cry to your momma
Ya don't tell me I didn't warn ya
Alrighty the-OH! Jesus!! ʕ •̀ o •́ ʔ
Check for traps too.
Who set these up??
Lucas?
(hoe don't do it) NOOO! *box explodes* (told ya pewds -_-)
FUCK I GOT BETRAYED :<
Of course it'll be fuckin- you're cool though barrel don't worry about it ;)
Is this a hub? Or is it just a random place?
random place
Ayy, alright
start with the weed
and check the computer
10 minutes after dose she died
5 minutes vomiting
Great
Hey its an iPad yay
What do we put there?
This thing?
The neurotoxin.
This is some freaky fucking experiments going on here.
fuck man, I'm so scared  (๑•﹏•)
I can't believe, I-I'm so late into this game and I'm still so fucking terriffied.
*sighs* Ah jeez
okay.
What do we got here?
Great. Singing ladies is always great isn't it? (nope)
~ shut the fuuuuuuuuck up ~
~ shut ...
Oh javla fan!! *Swedish swears*
Oh my God >.<
That doesn't sound good
That doesn't sound good at all
Ummm....  . ___ .
*moist monster appears*
Oh. Great thanks for coming
Oh my God
Guys.
One at a time please.
Ah, this is...
*maniac insane laughter*
the worst thing that has ever happened to me.
How did I fuck that up?
How did I...
fuck this up?
Oh my God
Why did you turn off the flashlight? It was nice
*roar of a bigger and moistier monster*
Oh my God!
Is that a-? (yes)
*shoots the moist monster*
Reload for fucks sake
(focused Pewds is focused)
Die JackSepticEye!
Oh my God
Right in the pUsSaY!
*nope he's not dead yet*
*now he is :D*
Fuck I don't wanna waste anymore ammo, just die.
Thank you
Thanks~   ~(＾◇^)/
*you're welcome*
*singing* yucadamushnebadabadanan *incoherent*
BOOOX!!!
Hell yeah motherfucka.
Hey look, I can go up here if I want.
*blows into microphone* (ouchie ;<)
my god.. whta a f*cking mess I am so stressed out
*climbing the ladder*
goddammit..
if you- if you scared watching can you imagine just playing like..
this is- this is intense
alright
we need to get out of this... cave
that would be nice
Let's squeeze through here ;D
Hopefully nothing BAD happens
oh my gawd..
its a box..
everybody its a box ~
say it with me
baxbaxabaxabaxbaxabaxs
ey look at that :D
the mind map... thanks, we need that now right?
save station! dededididi~
this might be one of the last :(
save stations
uh. *tearing up* makes me sad :(
i'm gonna leave ya D: it's been a really fun week
it's been a really really fun week
i hope you enjoyed it as well (aww yes we did pewds)
OOOH MY GOD GRANNEH!
there's an item here
*rotates doll* AH POODIEPIE UR BAHDJSJFKSAGAINNNN
ahmazing!  (*^｡^*)   *chuckling*
FUCK youu *gunshot*
waste of ammo #worthit
GRANNEH
i've seen SO many comments abo- HEUHH JAVLA FITA *swedish*
nnn-no the door is right there..
oh!
E 001
ok i remember... i remember!~ :D
SOOO many comments be like "granny's gonna be the last boss D:"
"i swear to god granny"s the last boss"
"dude i bet granny's the last boss"
some of them seemed like speculating... some of them seemed like spoilers
but- it's granny time! :D
it's granny time mutha- Zoe? :/
*beeping*
sad :(
oh jeez... OH YEAH THIS IS WHERE WE WERE!!!!
fuck this place is shit -_-
you fuckin' little bitch
i remember
yeah what's happenin'
fuck off -__-
i'm looting
theres literally nothin' here -.-
what is this?
no
jesus-
she's creepy
but I-I'll be your daddy! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
ahh mah gawd..
alright
bitch needs to dieee
ehhh looks it ah meeee
beautifulll :*
looks so gooood
but i put myself everwhere in the house
JESUS
so creepyyyy
my gawd
*really terrifying laughter*  ~( ~´･_･`)~
whaaatt
i'll never play nice
OH MAH GAWD
uhhhhh-
oh this is awkward...
oh my god *chuckle*
you don't understaiiind
faack me man
this is not good  -. __ .-
OH GAWD
WHAT THE FAACK D:
JEEZZ..
its like
calm down, what did i ever-
AHH GAWD
FAACK
no
you cant fart you're way away from me
OH GOD
GOTTT EMMM
THATS RIGHT BITCH-
HAHAHAHA
HAHAHAHA  ಠﭛಠ
YESS
ITS GRANNEY
GARNNEY
GRANEEE
HAYY
cuz you're old and ugly and-
and you're mascaras leaking a lil bit
oh gawd you're so moist..
EHHHHH D:
EHHHHHH :<
YEAH, CUZ YOU'RE MOIST >o<
UGHH :X
AAA-
GROSS
YUCK
UEGH
GROSS
great
she infested the whole house -_-
awhh jezz..
OH MY FUCKING LORD   ( ･ั﹏･ั)
lemme just..
what is happening here?
TOP'O DA MORNIN' TA YA
DIE GRANNEH
DIEEEEE
I'VE BEEN WANTING TO DO DIS
FOR A LOOONG TIME
oh sorry-
leeme reload >.<
fuck
she's coming close
i can't help at the fact that she's coming a lil bit close
she is 100% kinda close
aaah gawd
oh boyy..
uhh hum
shet
WHAT?
THAT WASS FUCKEN IT?
NOPE
DEFINITELY
OH MY FUCKING GAWD
OH MY..LOARD    ( ⚆ _ ⚆ )
uhh
how you doin' granney
oh fuck it hurts granneh
hurt my feelings :c
OW
IS THERE ANYTHING I CAN DO FOR YA GRANNEY
OH MY GAWWDD
AWHHH
THIS IS BAD FOR ME GRANNEY
THIS IS REALLY BAD FOR ME GRANNEY
UH-GRENADE
OH MAH GOD
I MEAN
STOP BEING UGLY
HOW BOUT THAT
HAVE YA TREID THAT
HAVE YA TRIED BEING STOP BIENG UGLY
lemme just reload really quick
there ya go
thats a family for ya
and then lets-
switch to anatha one
there's your family
hows that for a family?
OH JESUS
HOW MUCH AM I ATTCKING ON THIS FUCKEN GRANNEY MAN
UNKNOWN
what? :O
oh.
what?
what was that?
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?
WHAT IS THIS?
WOAH
WOAHH
HELL YEA
HELL YEAHH
OH MY GAWD
WHAT WAS THAT?
ALBERT-
WHO THE FUCK IS ALBERT?
IS THAT A REFERENCE FROM AN OLDER GAME?
IT SEEMED LIKE IT
CUZ IT WAS FROM-
soemone explain
i'm really curious
WE DID IT
I AM SO PROUD
AH FEEL FUCKIN' AMAZING
my gawd..
i'm emotional right now
godammit
what a fuckin' journey
just watch this..
who the f*ck are you
Don't care
you wearin' lip lip ahmm..
lip balm ?
The f*ck took you guys so long
So nice
Hey its Mia
(No)
Hooo...thats how the game started
Thats how it started
Umbrella corp!
Yeah...I dont know about that *weird sound and face*
Haa..lets see
*rip headphone user*
Heyyyyyyy...ii
I just saw that it say seven...im so in the logo
I was like why are the highlight F,V and the I
Oh my god whats happening
Oh my god
What is happening?
They always have to end it badly
Is this the credits?(Yes it is)
Yeah it is
Director Koshi Naka--
Ahhhh
I lost my phone
*exhale*
A+(me too)
An amazing game,thank you for sharing it with me or joining me rather
With me I shit...I shed
Ahh
That was fucking amazing...what a amazing game
What a great horror game they really rest directed the resident evil genre
It so different
So different
Like its uncompareable
To me at least--like compare to resident evil 5 its a fucking joke
This game is so good
Compare to a--
Ermm...I thrilled...I thrilled like get to*pood thinking*
Finally do a series on this channel
And the--
uhh you know
i'm glad i- uh went with my guts and just wait for a games
that i think are gonna be good
and focus on them rather than just playing
all the games cause they wouldn't be as special.
I think these ones are special and uhh
it's a really cool thing to be sharing online
It wouldn't be possible without you guys watching it so
*muah*
There are so many people playing this game and the fact that you chose me to-
uhhhh
watch it with  i rb- uh i think that means a lot (aww pewdie!)
and its very ... very flattering for me
so.. yeah.
I'm really late so i'm just gonna uh skip the credits
and hopefully there's nothing behind it
fuck's sake. I guees i hate to  wait
I'll cut myself out
Brofist! (d'awwww! ) :D
*end credits*